[Music]  Selena Gomez stepped out to support the  weekend in NYC  but before cheering on her beau in  concert Selena  satisfied her sweet tooth hey fella what  are you doing  I got a cheesecake before my workmen  trousers the popstar attended her  boyfriends show at the Barclay center  wearing a latex mini dress and red tank  top paired with matching sneakers at one  point Selena was spotted dancing to the  weekend performance in the crowd  [Music]  following the show the good for you  singer made a quick change for dinner at  carbon Selena appeared to go braless  slipping into a sexy black dress with a  daring slit as she walked hand in hand  with the star boy singer and the couple  continued to pack on the PDA outside the  restaurant  Selena shared a clip getting cozy with  her men in the car can't keep my hands  to myself  [Music]